Das geht ja jetzt schon los, dass bei Yoga
Kursen gefragt wird, darf ich einen Yoga
Kurs anbieten oder Pilates Kurse
oder Taekwondo. Das heißt, was bleibt meinem
Sechsjährigen jetzt, der deutsche
Sport? Max Schmeling Sport, also Boxen
und ich esse nur deutsches
Essen und deutsche Tattoos. Das ist ja
-der feuchteste AfD Traum ever.
-13 Fragen. Hier kommt die erste:
Dreadlocks, Federschmuck oder Hip-Hop-
ist kulturelle Aneignung diskriminierend?
Wenn ihr sagt, ja, eher ja, dann
bitte auf dem grünen Feld positionieren.
Wenn ihr sagt, eher nein, dann bitte
aufs gelbe Feld. Und bitte. Okay, jetzt wissen
wir, wo ihr steht, aber wo steht ihr?
In der Musik, beim Karneval, in der Mode
oder beim Essen- die sogenannte
kulturelle Aneignung gibt es ja eigentlich schon seit
immer, auf die eine oder andere
Weise, aber die Diskussion darüber hat
in den letzten Jahren
ordentlich an Tiefe und Schärfe gewonnen.
Beispielhafter Vorwurf: Billie Eilish,
oder hierzulande Shirin David, würden sich
afroamerikanischer Musik und Mode
bedienen, damit ordentlich Asche
verdienen, aber ohne jeglichen Hinweis
auf kulturelle oder historische Backgrounds.
Die Frage dahinter ist also: Darf man
zum Beispiel Hip-Hop einfach als Lifestyle
leben, ohne jegliche Reflexion,
woher diese Musikrichtung überhaupt kommt?
Dürfen Weiße Dreadlocks tragen? Darf
ich mich an Karneval als Geisha verkleiden?
Eher nein, sagen die einen,
denn kulturelle Aneignung, zumal
bei marginalisierten Gruppen, kann
eben zur Diskriminierung derer führen,
die ich nachzuahmen versuche. Naja,
sagen die anderen. Kulturelle Aneignung, das gab
es ja schon immer in Musik und Mode
und beim Essen und so weiter. Das kann ja
auch eine Form der Wertschätzung
sein. Bei 13 Fragen suchen wir den Kompromiss.
Die Frage ist: Wie sieht der in dieser Frage
aus? Und wie kommen die beiden
Gruppen am Ende des Tages, am Ende
dieser Folge also, näher aufeinander zu?
Wo würdet ihr euch positionieren? Auf der grünen
Seite? Ja, kulturelle Aneignung
eher problematisch. Oder auf der gelben?
Nö, eigentlich ganz okay. Schreibt's mir
gerne in die Kommentare. Also, wenn ihr der Gegenseite
in einem Punkt zustimmt,
dann dürft ihr gerne einen Schritt
nach vorne gehen. Und wenn ihr sagt, na ja,
grundsätzlich finde ich das, was du
sagst gar nicht so schlecht, aber da erzählst du
wirklich völligen Quatsch, dann dürft
ihr auch gerne einen Schritt zurückgehen.
Mein Ziel ist es natürlich, am Ende
möglichst viele von euch in die Mitte
zu bewegen, damit wir eben in Richtung
Kompromiss, vielleicht sogar Konsens uns
bewegen. Das ist ja das Ziel der ganzen
Sendung. 13 Fragen: Hier kommt Frage
Nummer zwei und die geht an Angelina.
Angelina, du bist ja tätig in einem
Friseursalon und du beschäftigst
dich auch zum Beispiel mit afrikanischer
Flechtkunst. Heutzutage will man
vielleicht Braids sagen. Das hast du
jahrelang gemacht und dann ergab
sich irgendwann ein Shitstorm über dich.
-Was ist passiert?
-Also ich praktiziere seit 17 Jahren
afrozentrische
Haarflechtkunst und bin eben auch spezialisiert
auf diese Gruppierungen. Und ich bin
mit Gambianern großgeworden, quasi von klein
auf und war sehr, sehr tief in dieser Kultur
drin verwurzelt. Und ich würde
sagen, seit fünf, sechs Jahren ging
dann diese Debatte um kulturelle Aneignung los.
Und das war dann das erste Mal,
dass ich mit so einer Gewalt, sage ich mal,
-mit diesem Thema konfrontiert wurde.
-Was war denn der Vorwurf?
Na ja, der Vorwurf war, dass ich quasi
eine Kultur beklauen würde und mich dann
daran in diesem Kontext in meinem
beruflichen Rahmen bereichern würde,
ohne quasi der Kultur etwas zurückzugeben.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass von beiden
Seiten sehr viel Schmerz, einfach
sehr viel Schmerz vorherrscht und sehr viel
Vorwurfshaltung und ich würde mir
wünschen, dass wir da, ja, einen Ausweg
aus diesem emotionalen ein bisschen
rausfinden sozusagen und mehr
ins Sachliche kommen, denn ich finde,
die Probleme liegen wesentlich tiefer,
wenn wir über Rassismus
sprechen als in irgendeiner Frisur.
Shanon. Würdest du bei ihr im Friseursalon
dir die Haare machen lassen?
-Respectfully, no.
-Was müsste denn passieren, dass du sagst,
hey, respectfully yes, ich gehe zu dir
in den Salon, weil ich den Eindruck habe,
du kennst sich aus mit dem, was du
tust und du kennst auch den Background?
Ich, für mich, kann mir das jetzt
gerade gar nicht vorstellen, dass ich sage,
ich gehe zu jemanden, der, ja,
nicht black ist, nicht of colour ist.
Was ich problematisch finde wenn eine weiße
Person einen Haarsalon eröffnet,
in dem afrikanische, schwarze
Frisuren als Service angeboten werden, ist,
dass ich an die Menschen denke, die das schon
jahrelang machen, schon von Kindheit
auf gelernt haben und einfach nicht
die gleichen Zugangsmöglichkeiten haben.
-Das ist das Problematische für mich.
-Warum ist es so ein tiefgründiges Ding?
Die Strukturen, in denen wir uns
bewegen, die sind per se rassistisch geprägt.
Und Haare, wie wir sie jetzt tragen,
wie wir sie jetzt sehen, waren oder sind immer
noch ein Riesenthema. Im Sinne von:
Kriege ich den Job, kriege ich die Wohnung,
werde ich als sympathisch
gelesen oder nicht? Das sind alles Themen.
Und wenn dann eben zum Beispiel eine weiße
Person sagt: Hey, ich mache jetzt
den Braiding Salon auf, ist per se
nicht das Problem, nur das, was alles mit dahin
einher geht, das ist das Problem. Dass eben
die gleiche Person, die sagen wir mal
von seit Kind an mit schwarzen Haaren
auch groß geworden ist, wie du es vielleicht
auch bist, das mag sein, und gleichzeitig
bekommt diese Friseurin zum Beispiel nicht
die gleichen Chancen. Vielleicht
nicht die gleichen Kunden mit den gleichen
Ressourcen, um im Endeffekt eine gleichwertige
Arbeit zu machen, wie du
-sie tust. Und das ist eben das Problem.
-Also wenn ich dich richtig verstanden
habe, so lange das grundsätzliche
System von Machtmissbrauch und Rassismus nicht
geändert wird, würdest du jetzt zum Beispiel
in einem weißen Braiding Salon
-nicht gerne Kundin sein?
-Ja.
Wenn es sich aber ändern würde,
würde sich das vielleicht auch wieder ändern.
Ja, das klingt nach einer Utopie,
meiner Meinung nach, auf die ich total gerne
hinsteuere oder hinarbeite.
Und gleichzeitig ist es einfach nicht
-der Status Quo.
-Hasnain, kannst du es nachvollziehen?
Ich kann nachvollziehen, was Shanon
sagte, mit dem, dass das System so ist
wie es ist, dass es Diskriminierung
gibt, dass man, wenn man schwarz ist, braun ist,
was auch immer, also PoC, dass man
eine Wohnung nicht bekommt, dass man
den Arbeitsplatz nicht bekommt, dass man
diskriminiert wird. Das ist so, das stelle
ich selbst auch in meinem Leben
fest. Aber die Lösung kann doch nicht sein,
dass ich dann selbst mich auf solche
Mechanismen zurückziehe und sage:
Und deswegen darf jemand, der weiß
ist, keinen Salon aufmachen und Rastalocken
machen. Genauso wie- das geht ja
nicht nur um diejenigen, die das machen,
sondern auch diejenigen, die Kunden
sind. Deswegen darf zum Beispiel jemand,
der weiß ist, sich keine
Rastalocken machen lassen. Von mir aus kann sich
Dieter aus Deggendorf
Rastalocken machen lassen, genauso wie Angelina
selbstverständlich einen Salon
machen darf. Das heißt, ich finde es falsch,
nach dieser Diagnose, dass diese Gesellschaft
ist wie sie ist, dann sich
zurück zu berufen und zu sagen,
deswegen gehe ich nicht zu jemandem wie ihr.
Das finde ich falsch, weil damit
verhärten wir diese Fronten, anstatt
dass wir sie aufbrechen. Ja, es gibt
ganz viel, wo angegriffen wird,
wo diskriminiert wird, was falsch ist.
Und ich finde auch gut, dass wir überhaupt
darüber reden. Aber ich würde allen,
die sich sofort angegriffen fühlen, sagen,
Leute, stellt euch mal ein bisschen
zurück und schaut, warum Leute was tun,
wenn sie es tun. Mit der Absicht
zu verletzen, ist es verletzend.
Wenn sie es aber tun, weil sie eigentlich
wertschätzen oder weil sie es einfach
schön finden, ist das keine Verletzung,
im Grunde genommen, auch wenn ihr euch selbst
-persönlich vielleicht verletzt fühlt.
-Hami, wo fängt denn für dich kulturelle
Aneignung im negativen Sinne an?
Also was sind deine Erfahrungen damit?
Ja, kulturelle Aneignung beginnt
für mich da, wenn Menschen, Betroffene,
verletzt werden. Und da liegt die Deutungshoheit
auch nicht bei Leuten,
die nicht betroffen sind. Der Fox
Eyes Trend ist ja gerade sehr prominent
und der ist für mich besonders
verletzend. Warum? Weil weiße Menschen sich
diese Augenform, meine Augenform
einfach schminken können,
ohne mit den alltäglichen
Diskriminierungserfahrungen leben
zu müssen. Ich kann am nächsten Tag
nicht meine Augenform ablegen. Für mich ist
mein Aussehen kein Trend. Und wenn ich so
was sehe, dann denke ich mir, ich wurde
in meiner Kindheit am laufenden Band
wegen meiner Augen diskriminiert. Mir wurde
Schlitzaugen und sonst was gegen den Kopf
geworfen. Und jetzt kommt da eine Gigi
Hadid oder eine weiße Nina aus der Nachbarschaft,
schminkt sich die Augen so
und es ist cool. Und das ist
eben das Problem. Die Menschen
der Dominanzgesellschaft entscheiden,
was cool ist, was Trend ist, was erlaubt ist.
Das ist nicht okay. Und ja, ich wäre
dafür, dass es einfach gelassen wird.
Also wenn du in deiner Kindheit
gehänselt wurdest, ist es dann nicht eigentlich ganz
cool, dass jetzt asiatische
Augen plötzlich- dass die Leute das haben
wollen? Also ich meine, ist doch eher
umgekehrt finde ich immer so ein Problem,
wenn, sagen wir mal in entweder afrikanischen
Gesellschaften
oder in Indien oder in asiatischen
Ländern alle so aussehen wollen wie weiße
Hollywoodstars. Und jetzt also
anfangen, entweder ihr Gesicht weiß zu schminken
oder irgendwelche Cremes zu nehmen
oder versuchen, sich die Augen zu vergrößern.
Also dass das, was du hast, zum Schönheitsideal
wird- kann doch nichts
besseres passieren. Ich lebe in Bayern.
Was passiert da normalerweise im Oktober?
Oktoberfest. Der Thailänder kommt
aus Bangkok am Franz Josef Strauß Flughafen
an mit der Thailänderin und das erste
was sie tun, ist sich eine Lederhose anziehen
und ein Dirndl. Sagt irgendjemand
in Bayern, das sei kulturelle Aneignung?
Nein, der Bayer ist stolz darauf, weil er das als Bestätigung
seiner Lebensweise
-empfindet.
-Shanon ist ganz nach hinten gelaufen, als
-Jan eingesetzt hat. Warum?
-Ich bin komplett raus, weil ein Aspekt,
der jetzt gerade auch tatsächlich
schon passiert, wo ich finde, wo noch mal
richtig deutlich wird, wie problematisch
diese Aneignung ist, dass nämlich
auch Stars wie Kim Kardashian sich
jetzt wieder zum Beispiel ihren Po verkleinern
hat lassen oder wieder zu Ursprungsform
zurückgekommen ist. Miley Cyrus hat sich
ihre Ästhetik, hat jetzt ihre Rap
Phase, ihre Hip-Hop Phase sozusagen hinter sich
und distanziert sich auch von Hip-Hop,
um in der Country Branche wieder ein bisschen
größer rauszukommen oder mehr Anklang
zu finden. Und genau das signalisiert halt,
ah okay, ich utilisiere diese kulturelle
Aneignung zu meinen Gunsten, wenn es mir
passt, wenn es mir gerade, für mich
gerade musikalisch, künstlerisch, mir
in die Karten spielt. Und jetzt, wo ich gemerkt
habe ah, den right wing Americans
gefällt irgendwie meine Hip-Hop
Anlehnung nicht so sehr oder Nähe nicht so sehr,
und ich brauche die aber und sage
jetzt, ah, ich habe jetzt die Phase durch
und präsentiere mich auch von der Ästhetik
wieder weißer. Also da ist halt wirklich
klar, es gibt diesen Umschwung
zugunsten von auch finanziellem Profit.
Okay, das ist ein Argument für dich.
Also der Kommerz und der Missbrauch
einer anderen Kultur aus Fame
Gründen. Das ist für dich ein wesentlicher Punkt.
Könnte es, und ich versuche dich zu verstehen,
könnte es ein Szenario geben,
in dem Miley Cyrus ihre Rap Phase
weiter kultiviert und irgendwann glaubhaft macht:
Ich finde diese Kultur so großartig,
ich will jetzt immer Teil dieser Kultur
sein und sie weiterleben? Könntest
du dir vorstellen, dass das möglich wäre
-bei einer Miley Cyrus?
-Nein, weil ich kann es mir sogar bei mir
nicht vorstellen, dass ich zum Beispiel
als schwarze Person authentisch
eine afroamerikanische Rap Kultur
repräsentieren könnte. Denn ich finde
ehrlich gesagt auch deutschen Rap
in der Hinsicht oft fragwürdig. Denn da,
wo diese Kultur wirklich herkommt,
die Umstände, in denen Menschen leben,
wirklich gelebt haben, die wurden
dann auf eine Art und Weise glorifiziert,
die einfach auch gar nicht der Realität
entsprochen haben. Und ich habe mich
in letzter Zeit viel mit Menschen
unterhalten, die wirklich in Projects
in der wirklichen Hood gelebt haben und dachte
mir, auf gar keinen Fall würde ich-
also ich habe ruandische und ugandische
Wurzeln, bin in Bayern und NRW groß
geworden. Ich habe noch nie in meinem
Leben ein Projekt, eine Hood etc,
oder noch nie in dieser prekären
Situation gelebt, wo ich tagtäglich für gar nichts
auf der Straße erschossen werden
kann. Und das ist die Kultur, aus der eben Rap
kommt. Das ist kein Spaß, das ist
nicht cool, das ist nicht witzig. Das,
wo es herkommt. Und wenn Miley
Cyrus das verstehen würde, glaube ich nicht,
wenn sie es wirklich verstehen würde,
glaube ich nicht, dass sie sich versuchen
würde im Rap Kontext zu präsentieren.
Denn nicht mal ich würde das tun.
Dann ist ja interessant, dass wir einen
Hip-Hop Experten neben dir stehen haben.
Alex, weiße Kartoffeln dürfen nach der Konsequenz
eigentlich keinen Rap mehr
-machen. Stimmst du zu?
-Also ich würde gerne diese "dürfen"- es
-geht ja darum-
-Sollten nicht.
-ist es diskriminierend, dass sie sich
kulturell Elemente aneignen. Dürfen...?
Du willst keine Verbote,
aber du findest es problematisch.
Also ich persönlich bin Fan von zu vielen
weißen Künstlern und Künstlerinnen,
um das so unterschreiben zu können.
Ich stehe auf der grünen Seite,
weil ich persönlich sehr froh darüber
bin, dass über kulturelle Aneignung endlich
diskutiert wird, auch in meinem
Umfeld, diskutiert wird. Ich bin eben ein weißer
cis Mann. Ich profitiere
von einer ursprünglich schwarzen,
marginalisierten Kulturform,
nämlich Hip-Hop, verdiene damit mein Geld.
Und es ist das Mindeste, dass ich mich
nach Jahren, in denen ich das leider nicht
gemacht habe, weil ich- weil mir
diese Diskussion erst über die Jahre bewusst
gemacht wurde, darüber nachdenke
und Credits gebe, eben auch und immer mal
wieder auch diesen backjump wage:
zurück zu den Wurzeln, wo kommt HipHop eigentlich
her? Auch wenn natürlich irgendwie
90 Prozent der RapperInnen, mit denen
ich mich irgendwie beschäftige oder die ich zum Interview
treffe, irgendwie weiß
sind, die Wurzeln liegen
woanders. Ich habe lange gedacht: Ah, okay,
Hip-Hop finde ich cool. HipHop King der Welt
ist Eminem, ein Weißer. Hip-Hop Kings
in Deutschland sind Aggro Berlin so,
also mit diesem Hip-Hop Verständnis bin
ich irgendwie aufgewachsen. Das hat mir
auch MTV irgendwie so suggeriert. Und erst
im Laufe der Jahre und durch
diese aufkommende Diskussion um kulturelle
Aneignung habe ich mich darin
irgendwie ein Stück weit reflektiert.
Weiß natürlich, bin noch nicht am Ende
dieses Reflexionsprozess angelangt.
Ist nicht Hip-Hop genau das Paradebeispiel
dafür, was entstehen kann, wenn man
aneignet? Und ich meine, wir haben
ja- außer Hip-Hop ist ja noch viel mehr
entstanden, auch die ganze Soul
Musik, Rock 'n' Roll, all das in ihren
verschiedenen Variationen, die wir jetzt
haben. Eine kulturelle Vielfalt, die sich
-entwickelt hat.
-Ja, mit einer großen Gemeinsamkeit. Es
sind alles im Prinzip
marginalisierte, auch teilweise protestgetriebene...
-Absolut.
-...Kunst-, Kulturformen, die allesamt von
weißen Dominanzkulturen ja wiederum
angeeignet wurden. Deswegen glaube ich,
ist es nicht optimal gelaufen und da ist
noch sehr, sehr viel Luft nach oben.
Ich denke, gerade wenn wir jetzt über
Hip-Hop sprechen, dann wäre es ein guter
Ansatz, zum Beispiel zu sagen,
gut, also Bildungsarbeit muss stattfinden,
Credits geben. Wie kann das aussehen
im Fall von HipHop? Heute vielleicht nicht
eine schwarze Tänzerin, die irgendwo
vierte Reihe im Background tanzt so,
sondern macht mal ein Feature mit einem
Künstler, vielleicht, der tatsächlich
die marginalisierte Position hat und die Perspektive
und daran mit profitieren
kann, damit Geld verdienen kann. Also
zum Beispiel in meinem Fall, ich bin Hip-Hop
Journalist. Ich habe mir
vorgenommen, mehr selber zu lernen über die Roots
dieser Kultur und darüber eben auch aufzuklären
auf den Plattformen, die mir
-zur Verfügung stehen.
-Aber du hast auch wieder den Punkt ins
Feld geführt, nämlich
Machtstrukturen. Erst mal sich dessen gewahr werden
und sie ernst nehmen und versuchen
sie aufzubrechen, indem man marginalisierte
-Menschen mit reinholt, über ein Feature.
-Genau, und eben nicht nur so low-key mit
reinholen, weil, ja irgendwie
mit reinholen, passiert irgendwas
im Hintergrund, sondern irgendwie
wirklich als ProtagonistInnen mit reinholen.
Jan, kannst du mit dieser Argumentation
mitgehen, dass du sagst, Mensch,
wir werden uns dessen bewusster?
Klar, Bildungsarbeit, man sagt ja bei jeder
Sendung am Ende, wir brauchen
mehr Bildung. Das stimmt schon auch. Aber
eine Aufmerksamkeit erzeugen,
Wissen erzeugen und dann im Wissen
der Machtstrukturen
besser damit umgehen können?
Also letztlich ist ja das, was ich schon
auch gesagt habe. Also eigentlich findet
sie es, weil es eben aus dem Ghetto
kommt, eine Sache schwarzer Leute. Und da sollten
die Weißen die Finger von lassen. Und wenn ich das weiter
denke, muss ich ja sagen,
das gilt auch für die Konsumenten.
Und das sind bittere, bittere Nachrichten
für alle, die mit Rapmusik
Millionäre geworden sind. Die, die noch Millionäre
geworden sind, für die ist es gut,
aber nun noch Millionäre werden wollen,
ist schlecht. Wenn also mein Publikum
nur noch dann besteht aus schwarzen Leuten
und ich, sage mal, diejenigen schon
mal rausnehme, die die haupt Consumergruppe
in Amerika sind, nämlich alle
weißen Mittelschichtskinder, dann wird
es jedenfalls finanziell
schonmal enger. Und ich frage mich,
welches Gesellschaftsbild steckt
dahinter? Ich meine, unsere Kultur besteht
aus Aneignung. Die Kartoffel,
obwohl wir jetzt Kartoffeln genannt werden,
kommt nicht aus Deutschland, wird für viele
Leute eine große Überraschung sein.
-Nein, sie kommt aus Südamerika.
-Wenn ich Jan richtig verstanden habe,
Shanon, dann ist deine Auffassung von kultureller
Aneignung- könnte dazu neigen,
dass wir kulturelle
Vielfalt aufgeben. Richtig verstanden?
Ich finde, man muss ein bisschen
gucken, dass die Spalten, in denen
wir argumentieren und diskutieren,
irgendwie so ein bisschen ähnlich bleiben,
weil sonst kommen wir auf gar keinen
grünen Nenner. Und ich würde mich total
freuen, wenn es uns gelingen würde,
auf einen grünen Nenner zu kommen. Denn,
Ziel finde ich, ist nicht zu sagen,
jeder muss in seiner eigenen Spalte bleiben,
sondern im Idealfall lernen wir alle
voneinander, von den unterschiedlichen
Kulturen. Aber mit welcher Haltung
und mit den Machtpositionen und Privilegien,
die unterschiedliche Leute eben
auch haben, geht einfach auch eine gewisse
-Verantwortung einher.
-Ich möchte aber noch mal was zu den Augen
sagen, zum Beispiel, wenn ich das nochmal
darf. Das ist mir sehr wichtig,
weil ich finde, ich kann diese Verletztheit
total nachvollziehen.
Dass man diskriminiert wurde, dass man
blöde Sprüche und Begriffe, die ich gar
nicht wiederholen möchte, gehört hat
und so weiter. Ich habe mein Leben lang immer
wieder Sprüche gehört, wegen meiner
Hautfarbe. Möchte ich auch gar keine
Begriffe nennen, aber da kann man
sich vorstellen, wenn man braune Haut hat,
bekommt man Sprüche zu hören. In deiner
Logik müsste ich jetzt sagen, jeder Weiße,
der sich bräunt, der sich sonnt,
macht etwas problematisches. Finde ich nicht
in Ordnung, weil ich habe braune Haut,
ich erleb das. Ihr entscheidet euch frei,
euch zu bräunen. Bräunen darf man nicht
mehr. Das finde ich absurd. Natürlich darf
sich jeder bräunen. Es ist doch
schön, wenn jemand dieses Ideal übernimmt.
Und trotzdem kritisiere ich diejenigen,
die mich beleidigen wegen meiner
Hautfarbe. Das heißt, diejenigen, die dich
beleidigt haben, wegen deiner Augenform,
dass du die kritisierst, bin ich sofort
bei dir. Und wenn die sich jetzt auch noch
die Augen so formen würden, wie-
oder schminken würden, wie du sie hast,
würde ich sie auch kritisieren, sagen,
aha, vorher hast du mich so und so genannt
und jetzt machst du es selbst? Das finde
ich ja so richtig. Aber grundsätzlich
zu sagen, es wäre problematisch,
dass Menschen, die eben nicht ostasiatisch
gelesen werden, dass die sich die Augen
so formen, das finde ich, das ist in Ordnung.
-Ich würde das auch als gut empfinden.
-Hami, das klingt doch plausibel.
Das Problem ist, zum einen, es wird
auch Stereotype reproduziert. Also nicht jeder
Asiatische oder asiatisch gelesene
Person hat zum Beispiel solche Augen. Aber
wenn alle sich genau gleich- bei diesem Fox
Eyes Trend, das ist genau klar
definiert, wie die Augen geschminkt
werden. Und wenn sich alle diese Augen
schminken und sie sehen und andere
sehen das und denken, ach ja, das sieht ja
asiatisch aus, dann wird eben diese Stereotype
von asiatisch gelesenen Augen
reproduziert. Und das ist
das Problematische daran.
Hätten wir jetzt, im Globus
sozusagen, nur den Fox Eyes Trend, ja, mein Gott,
dann haben wir alle besseres zu tun,
als uns jetzt um diesen Fox Eye Trend alleine
zu kümmern. Aber es geht einfach
um die Vielzahl. Es geht darum- es geht
um Verkleidungen. Es geht darum, dass ich mich
eben kommerziell wesentlich besser
darstellen kann, positionieren kann.
Es geht- noch mal, also wir reden wirklich
um Lebensraum, den manche Menschen
einfach verwehrt bekommen und andere dafür immer
wieder gepriesen werden. Es ist so
eine riesen Vielzahl. Es ist genauso verkehrt,
zum Beispiel, sich als KZ-Insasse
zu verkleiden. Warum? Weil einfach so
ein riesen Gräuel damit einhergeht,
mit der Geschichte, die damit einher gegangen
ist. Und da wir verstanden haben,
wie schrecklich das war, warum sollte
es witzig sein, sich so zu verkleiden?
Denn was da passiert ist-
00:20:27,160 --> 00:20:27,020
-Den Punkt verstehe ich.
-- ist dass Menschen da so einfach
-karikatiert werden.
-Ich würde gerne wissen, verstehst du den
Punkt auch? Das ist ja nun ein sehr drastisches,
extremes Beispiel.
-Das ist wirklich was anderes, also...
-Na gut, es geht um marginalisierte Gruppen
-im weitesten-
-...aber das ist ein Unterschied, ob ich
-mich...
-KZ- Native American. Wo-?
Also zum Beispiel als Sklave
verkleidet. Ich gehe als Sklave auf eine Party.
Oder würde ich mal sagen, sozusagen
als Leidensfigur. Das ist ein komisches
Kostüm, weil es ja nun was anderes,
als ob ich mich als Indianer, in diesem Fall
-Häuptling oder Pirat oder-
-Native American.
Und das ist interessant.
Warum ist es ein Unterschied?
-Als Sklave?
-Der Sklave und Native American zum
-Beispiel?
-Der Indianer heute, glaube ich, sieht sich
jetzt nicht notwendigerweise als Leidensfigur.
Es gibt sehr viele Leute,
die sehr stolz auf ihre Herkunft
sind. Ich habe die ganze Diskussion
um den Indianerhäuptling nicht
verstanden, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe vier Jahre
in Amerika gelebt. Es gibt keinen
Indianer in Amerika, der an dem Wort Indianer
-Anstoß nimmt.
-Es gibt sie schon. Vielleicht hast du sie
-nicht getroffen.
-Aber es ist in Amerika, auch unter den
Indianern kein problematischer
Begriff. Das heißt glaube ich Indian National
Congress, ist die oberste
Standesversammlung der Indianer
in Amerika. Das ist, ich glaube, eine Vorstellung
wiederum von- weiß gar nicht,
wo das herkommt, vom Grünen-Parteitag,
wo Leute das Gefühl haben, könnte
ein schwieriger Begriff sein. Wir versuchen
rückgängig zu machen den Prozess
der Globalisierung, des Kapitalismus.
Da kann man drüber klagen. Es ist natürlich
so, dass unser System besteht daraus,
dass wir, wenn wir uns wollen, andere Dinge
aneignen. So, und was ich so
eigenartig finde, was ist die Alternative? Das geht
ja jetzt schon los, dass sie bei Yoga
Kursen gefragt wird, darf ich einen Yoga
Kurs anbieten oder Pilates Kurse
oder Taekwondo. Das heißt, was bleibt meinem
Sechsjährigen jetzt, der deutsche
Sport? Max Schmeling Sport, also Boxen
und ich esse nur deutsches Essen,
weil das- und deutsche Tattoos, was immer
das ist, also sozusagen der Anker
aus Hamburg, wo ich herkomme
aus der Hansestadt? Das ist sozusagen,
das ist ja der feuchteste AfD Traum ever.
Also es heißt, jeder bleibt in seiner
Kultur, was immer das heißt. Und da gehe
ich nicht mehr mit. Ich will
nicht in einer AfD Kultur leben.
Entschuldige, dass ich noch mal
zurückkomme, weil ich noch nicht ganz
verstanden habe, wo der Unterschied
für dich liegt. Also, Native Americans,
Indigene, die ja
nachweislich jahrhundertelang unterdrückt,
abgeschlachtet und so weiter wurden,
da findest ist es unproblematisch, sich
als ein solcher zu verkleiden,
aber bei den Sklaven in Anführungszeichen,
die eine ähnliche Leidensgeschichte
hinter sich haben, siehst du- findest du
es problematisch? Warum? Was ist
der Unterschied? Was ist das Kriterium?
Wir versuchen
nachzuvollziehen, wo könnte eine Grenze verlaufen?
Die Grenze ist bei einem- ich weiß
immer gar nicht, also wenn ich jetzt sagen
wir mal als Sklave- würde ich jetzt
mit Ketten und irgendwie was aufgeschminktem-
ist ja der Fantasie keine Grenzen
gesetzt- Streben von einer Auspeitschung gehe
ich auf eine offene Kostümparty,
um welchem Punkt zu machen? Sich lustig
zu machen darüber, dass Menschen
bitteres Unrecht erlitten haben oder furchtbar
gelitten haben? Das ist doch eine kategorial
andere Geschichte, als sagen
wir mal, mich zu verkleiden als eine andere
Volksgruppe, als Tiroler
-meinetwegen oder als Bayer.
-Könnt ihr das nachvollziehen?
Ich hätte da eine Rückfrage, wenn du
an ein Kostüm von einem indigenen Menschen
denkst, woran denkst du?
Wahrscheinlich an Federn, an Kopfschmuck.
Ja, was Kinder sich-
also was wir uns natürlich auch-
-An Bemalungen?
-Karl May, oder?
Es ist ja- gut, ich weiß nicht, ob du
mal jemals in einem indianischen Reservat
-in Amerika-
-Es geht ja um die Wahrnehmung, die man
hier hat. Also ich muss dafür jetzt
nicht nach Amerika reisen, sondern das was man
ja bei einem sogenannten Indianer
Kostüm sieht, das sind ja Kopfschmuck, Federn
und so weiter. Und das ist doch genau
die Form, das ist doch nichts- fast nichts
anderes als Peitschwunden, also als Wunden
von Auspeitschungen, weil indigene Völker
wurden aufgrund dessen ermordet. Weil sie anders
ausgesehen haben, weil sie diesen-
Federn waren jahrelang verboten.
Dass wir heute davon profitieren können
und dass wir wissen, dass es so was überhaupt
gibt, war ganz allein die Arbeit
von indigenen Menschen, die das über
Generationen hinweg überliefert haben
und es geschafft haben zu überliefern.
Und deswegen ist für mich da- das ist für mich
klar. Also das ist
für mich sehr vergleichbar.
Was ist mit dem Thailändern,
Chinesen, sonst was, die zum Oktoberfest kommen
und sich Lederhose anziehen und Dirndl,
die Frauen und so weiter, das ist
auch kulturelle Aneignung. Dürfen sie das?
Und ist es in Ordnung? Natürlich, ist doch
-total in Ordnung.
-Shanon, was sagst du denn? Die chinesische
Familie, die zum Oktoberfest fährt
und sich Lederhosen anzieht. Auch kulturelle
Aneignung, ganz klar, ist
das problematisch oder nicht?
Wenn die asiatische Familie zum Oktoberfest
geht und sich bayerische
traditionelle Tracht anzieht, ist
es deshalb etwas anderes, weil einfach
die Geschichte, die dahinter steht,
jetzt von, ich sage mal Bayern, so soweit
ich weiß, ich bin auch in Bayern
groß geworden, teilweise- erinnere ich mich
jetzt nicht, dass in jüngster
Vergangenheit oder auch in älterer
Vergangenheit Bayern versklavt
wurden, unterjocht wurden oder sich jemals
ein anderes Volk oder die Mehrheitsgesellschaft
über Bayern lustig
gemacht hat, dass Bayern deswegen keinen
Zugang zu Bildung bekommen, wenn man
irgendwie Julius Engelberger heißt
oder Julian Engelberger heißt, zu sagen, oh,
bayerischer Nachname, die klauen eh
oder die wollen wir hier nicht haben, das hat
nicht stattgefunden. Und deswegen ist
es was anderes.
Hasnain, ist das ein valides Argument
für dich? Also ich fasse noch mal zusammen:
Bayern sind aktuell nicht, in der Regel
nicht Rassismen unterworfen, wie es andere
Bevölkerungsgruppen sind. Deswegen ist
die kulturelle Aneignung der bayerischen
Kultur weniger
problematisch als bei anderen Kulturen.
Nein, das kann für mich überhaupt gar
kein Maßstab sein, denn ich habe viele Jahre
in Pakistan gelebt, als Korrespondent.
Ich habe ja Wurzeln in Indien und Pakistan,
habe dort als Korrespondent auch gelebt.
Und wie wir wissen, war der indische
Subkontinent jahrhundertelang von Briten
kolonialisiert. Als ich dort gelebt habe,
habe ich sehr viele Briten, weiße
Briten kennengelernt, in Pakistan, in Indien,
die dort als Entwicklungshelfer waren,
Geschäftsleute, Diplomaten, Journalisten,
alles Mögliche. Und diese weißen
Menschen, Frauen wie Männer, haben dort
auch indische, pakistanische
Kleidung getragen. Salwar Kamiz, so ein langes-
knielanges Hemd und so eine Pluderhosen,
sieht so ein bisschen Pyjama mäßig aus,
haben also im Grunde genommen
die Kleidung der Menschen übernommen,
die sie jahrhundertelang
kolonialisiert haben. Und das hat niemand
als problematisch- sondern im Gegenteil
ist es ein Zeichen der Wertschätzung.
Die haben sich heute so bewegt wie viele
andere Menschen auch. Sie haben sich
sozusagen eingefügt. Ich fand das auch,
empfand das auch als etwas Gutes
und Schönes. Nun könnte man
natürlich sagen, das ist kulturelle Aneignung,
was wagt ihr, euch so zu kleiden?
Ihr habt uns jahrhundertelang unterdrückt,
ausgebeutet, ihr seid immer noch hier
als Entwicklungshelfer und tretet teilweise
auf wie die Herrscher über uns. Aber
nein, die Menschen sehen das eigentlich
überwiegend als Wertschätzung, also
nur weil jemand sich diskriminiert fühlt,
das kann für mich nicht das Kriterium
sein. Gleichwohl nehme
ich diese Diskriminierung oder diese Verletztheit
wahr und höre darauf.
Also die Motivation der Wertschätzung,
die jetzt- das Beispiel ist ja
ein interessantes Beispiel. Du hast
ja gesagt, das sind quasi die ehemaligen
Kolonialherren, die sich jetzt immer
hier noch teilweise als Herrscher aufführen.
Und als Zeichen der Wertschätzung
kleiden sie sich aber so ähnlich. Und offenbar
finden die Menschen das vor Ort,
wie du es erlebt hast, sogar positiv.
-Ja.
-Habe ich richtig verstanden. Was sagt ihr
dazu? Ist das überhaupt
denkbar in eurem- in eurer Logik?
Also ich finde die Umfrage total
spannend, wirklich von den Pakistani dann zu hören,
unter sich, ganz ehrlich, wie sie das tatsächlich
finden, denn es klingt
für mich danach, als würden sie immer
noch semikolonisiert werden oder immer noch
von den Auswirkungen der Kolonisation,
die Dynamiken, da immer noch so schwingen.
Und da frage ich mich, inwieweit
fühlen die sich überhaupt frei, dann
dem deutschen Reporter, den deutschen
Korrespondenten etc. dann wirklich
zu sagen: Du ganz ehrlich. Und das Ding
ist mit den ganzen Ismen, das Ding
mit den ganzen Ismen ist ja auch,
dass viele Menschen, die auch marginalisiert
sind und selbst davon betroffen sind,
erst mal lernen müssen, dass das überhaupt
der Stand der Dinge ist. Denn nur weil es vielleicht
eine andere Person gibt,
die zum Beispiel so aussieht wie ich und sagt,
ja, mein Homie, der nennt mich
das N-Wort. Für mich ist das vollkommen
in Ordnung. So. Am Ende des Tages muss
natürlich jede Person das für sich
selbst auch klar kriegen. Gleichzeitig: viele
von uns müssen erst mal verstehen, wie die Ismen
überhaupt wirken. Und nur weil jetzt
eine Person zwei Personen, drei,
vier, fünf sagen, dass das in Ordnung ist,
bedeutet das nicht, dass es in Ordnung
ist. Ich meine, es waren 1945 viele Dinge
in der Mehrheitsgesellschaft in Ordnung,
von denen Menschen gesprochen haben,
die aber einfach de facto aus der heutigen
Perspektive überhaupt nicht in Ordnung
waren. Das ist nicht
der Indikator unbedingt.
Jetzt ist Hasnain
nach hinten gelaufen. Warum?
Ja, also, weil ich diese Argumentation
wirklich absurd finde. Man möchte,
man sollte erst mal hören, wie die Pakistanerinnen
und Pakistaner intern
reden darüber. Erstens: Ich bin
selbst auch Pakistaner, ja, habe pakistanische
Wurzeln und fühle mich auch als solcher,
vielleicht zu einem kleineren Anteil,
als als Deutscher. Aber natürlich bin
ich das auch und das klingt ja fast schon so,
nur weil du das so empfindest,
das nehmen wir nicht ernst, weil du
das als Wertschätzung emfindest, weil in Wahrheit
denken die ja noch ganz anders.
Und wenn sie nicht anders denken,
sondern das als Wertschätzung empfinden, dann sind
sie noch nicht gebildet genug, noch
nicht sozusagen erzogen genug, sondern sie sind
immer noch in Wahrheit
kolonialisiert. Und das finde ich ehrlich gesagt
eine Unverschämtheit. Also
das geht überhaupt gar nicht,
sondern selbstverständlich
respektiere ich, wenn viele Pakistanerinnen
und Pakistaner sagen, ich empfinde das als Wertschätzung,
und dann möchte ich nicht,
dass man den Leuten sagt, oder mir
sagt, du bist dann immer noch kolonialisiert,
-also das geht nicht.
-Wie geht es euch aktuell? Habt ihr für
euch eine sinnhafte Lösung gefunden?
Könnt ihr diese oder diese Argumente besser
nachvollziehen? Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare.
Ich würde ganz gerne mal kurz
Angelina wieder mit ins Boot holen,
weil wir haben jetzt länger nichts von dir
-gehört. Wie geht es dir gerade?
-Also das, was hier eben gesagt wurde,
diese Erfahrung mit, eigentlich wird es als Wertschätzung
gesehen, diese Erfahrung
habe ich auch gemacht, weil als ich mich
mit dieser kulturellen Aneignung
beschäftigt habe, bin ich selber auch nach Afrika
gereist. Ich war in Westafrika,
ich war dort in den Salons, ich habe
dort in den schwarzen Familien gelebt, am Leben
teilgenommen und auch mich mit diesen Dingen
befasst und auch erfragt,
wie es dort gesehen wird. Und dort
ist dieses Thema überhaupt nicht bekannt.
Die Menschen haben sich fast schon
beleidigt gefühlt, als ich nur ansatzweise
das geschildert habe und konnten das nicht
nachempfinden. Und so habe ich für mich
den Schluss daraus gezogen, dass es wirklich
ein europäisches Problem ist,
also so ein eurozentristisches
Problem. Ich führe auch Kurse durch, also
ich unterrichte quasi auch Friseure,
die bereits in der Branche tätig sind,
in besonderen Bereichen in dieser Schiene,
die sich dafür interessieren
und weiterbilden möchten. Ich selber
beschäftige auch Menschen, die aus Afrika
kommen, diverse Kulturen, also
sowohl Jamaikaner als auch Afrikaner, es ist
irgendwie alles bei uns dabei. Und es ist
wirklich wie so eine Art familiäre
Atmosphäre, in der wir uns über genau
diese Themen austauschen und sehr gesund
austauschen. Diese ganze Debatte-
also dieses Gespräch um was dürfen wir,
was dürfen wir nicht?- ich finde,
da kratzen wir immer noch
sehr an der Oberfläche. Und da würde
ich mir zum Beispiel wünschen, dass man sich
irgendwie Mechanismen überlegt, wie kann
man Antirassismusarbeit in den Schulen
betreiben? Wie können wir aufhören,
an der Oberfläche zu kratzen und mehr
in die Tiefe zu gehen und wirklich
lösungsorientiert einfach zu leben
und zu arbeiten und nicht ständig
einander zu beschimpfen mit Vorwürfen und so
weiter? Weil so kommen
wir einfach nicht zum Ergebnis.
Das war ja der eigentliche Sinn
dieser Veranstaltung auch hier. Mal sehen wie-
aber immerhin, du hast es immerhin
geschafft, dass ihr drei so zaghaft
nach vorne gelaufen
seid, wieso eigentlich?
Zum Beispiel Angelina, als du davon
gesprochen hast, dass du eben auch Kurse
gibst, dass du Menschen anstellst
aus Jamaika, Afrika etc. Da dachte ich mir,
wie cool wäre es, wenn du sozusagen
das Privileg immer hast, da gut vernetzt,
vielleicht auch die Skills zu haben
und das Know how, Menschen Jobs zu geben,
wie cool wäre es, sich da einfach die Frage
zu stellen- ich lese dich als weiße
Frau- warum muss ich jetzt als weiße
Frau schwarzen Menschen zeigen, erklären,
wie sie mit ihren Haaren umgehen
können. Was ist an der Struktur noch machbar,
was kann verändert werden? Wie kann
ich meine Privilegien, meine Zugänge
vielleicht teilen, um anderen Menschen
auch Zugang zu diesen Ressourcen zu geben,
dass sie dieses Know how selber
strukturell verbreiten können? Denn
das ist ja oft das Problem,
was dahinter steht.
-Ja.
-So das Thema Verantwortung. Wie gehe ich
mit den Privilegien, die ich habe, um?
Wie kann ich anderen Menschen, die weniger
privilegiert sind, einfach daran
teilhaben lassen, um eben einfach strukturell
eine Veränderung herbeizuführen? Denn
es geht ja darum, dass wir eine Schieflage
von hunderten von Jahren versuchen
einfach lediglich gleichzusetzen. Es geht nicht
darum, dass irgendjemand
jemand anderem was wegnehmen möchte,
sondern wir versuchen immer noch,
eine Schieflage einfach gerade zu rücken.
Ja, ich verstehe, was du sagst und ich bin
mir auch über diese Privilegien absolut
bewusst. Und ich finde, dass ich nach meinem
Ermessen bereits alles mögliche
in meiner Macht stehende tue, um der Kultur
was zurückzugeben. Sei es durch
Integration von schwarzen Personen,
die bei uns arbeiten, sei es durch credits.
Dann, am Ende des Tages, ich bediene
ja Schwarze, also ich bediene natürlich
Andersfarbige, ich lehne ja nicht
einen Kunden ab, weil er jetzt weiß ist, so,
aber ich versuche quasi alles, was in meiner
Macht steht und meine Ressourcen,
meine Privilegien zu nutzen,
zugunsten von marginalisierten Gruppierungen
und auch im Bereich
Antirassismusarbeit, auch im Bereich Aufklärungsarbeit.
Und ich finde, mehr kann man da fast
gerade schon gar nicht tun. Mein großes
Ziel, und das ist so wirklich das,
was an der Spitze steht, wäre, dass man
auf institutioneller Ebene dieses Handwerk
sichtbar macht und integriert wirklich
in das Friseurhandwerk und es ja,
als ernst zu nehmendes Handwerk einfach
definiert, weil das ist das, was jetzt
gerade fehlt. Weil das würde nämlich
ermöglichen, dass sehr viele Menschen
mit afrikanischen Background, die gerade
illegal irgendwo zu Hause für Hungerlohn
8 Stunden lang Rasterzöpfe flechten,
endlich mal die Möglichkeit hätten,
ihren Beruf auszuüben und dafür eine adäquate
Bezahlung zu bekommen. Das ist
mein Ziel und das war immer meine Vision,
nicht irgendeine Kultur zu klauen,
mich daran zu bereichern und einfach ignorant
zu sein, sondern eher das Gegenteil,
das zu wertschätzen und zu integrieren.
Ich würde dich jetzt einfach gerne
eine halbe Stunde weiterreden lassen,
dann würden die anderen nämlich hier
vorne in der Mitte stehen. Du hast es also
geschafft, dass alle drei nach vorne
gegangen sind. Ich muss leider noch mal
den Bösen spielen, jetzt in dieser Geschichte,
weil ich weiß sehr sicher,
auch aus der Erfahrung aus vergangenen
Sendungen, die so ähnlich gelaufen sind,
dass jetzt ganz viele Leute an ihrem
mobilen Endgerät sitzen und sich fragen:
was soll ich jetzt noch mal machen?
Also versuchen, ein Kriterium, einen Weg
zu finden, wie sie mit dieser Debatte
umgehen können. Hami, kannst du
eine Faustregel geben für alle, die jetzt
gerade denken: Ich bin lernbegierig,
aber ich bin
verunsichert. Gibt es eine Faustregel?
Ich glaube, eine Faustregel, die werden
wir heute hier nicht finden in dem Rahmen.
Da braucht es einfach noch viel mehr
Input, auch von verschiedenen, noch viel
mehr Positionen. Ich möchte aber
gerne noch was zu dem Thema- noch kurz
zu Privilegien sharen und sich
bereichern. Ein gutes Beispiel dafür sind zum Beispiel
asiatische oder thailändische
Restaurants, die ja von VertragsarbeiterInnen mühsam
als Nischenökonomie, also als Nische
aufgebaut wurden und die aber
in der Sackgasse geendet ist. Viele
haben einfach ihr Restaurant, arbeiten 60
Stunden am Tag und es geht nicht
weiter. Dann gibt es eben eine weiße Person,
einen hippes Startup in Berlin von zwei
weißen Männern. Und die eignen sich
bestimmte Dinge von der asiatischen
Küche an und werden aber steinreich davon,
-werden berühmt, werden Pioniere.
-Das ist die Frage jetzt: Was ist dein
Plädoyer daraus? Diese Analyse ist
klar, ist dein Plädoyer jetzt: weiße Dudes,
lasst das mit euren Restaurants? Oder sagst
du: weiße Dudes, wenn ihr es schon
macht, dann sagt wenigstens, woher
ihr es habt. Also was? Wofür plädiert du?
Also ich plädiere für shared eure Privilegien.
Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel
ein Restaurant habe und ich möchte
gerne Fusionküche machen, dann gib doch auch mal
einem japanischen Koch die Bühne, oder gib
mal einem mexikanischen Koch die Bühne.
Und dafür plädiere ich: Für einen
Austausch auf Augenhöhe, von dem nicht
nur die Person der Dominanzgesellschaft
profitieren. Und das auch wirklich
-monetär, materiell.
-Hasnain, kannst du nachvollziehen? Also
jetzt reden wir über essen. Wir haben
jetzt verschiedene Beispiele, jetzt sind
wir mal beim Essen
gelandet, finde ich ganz gut.
Das Essensbeispiel ist so eins, auf das ich nur wartete,
dass das darauf kommt,
dass wir darüber reden, wo ich auch denke,
natürlich, darf ein türkischer Koch
in Mexiko ein Star werden mit einem
Kimchi Restaurant. Darf er. Und wenn er damit
monetär erfolgreich wird, herzlichen
Glückwunsch! Also ich mein gerade Küche
ist ja etwas, was davon lebt, dass man
Fusion macht, dass man Traditionen
übernimmt, dass man ausprobiert, dass man
Sachen entwickelt und dass Dinge dann
irgendwann tatsächlich auch nicht
mehr einer Kultur zuzuordnen sind.
-Shanon.
-Was ich halt auch, um das zu
unterstreichen, was du sagst,
so unglaublich gewaltvoll finde, ist,
sich anzugucken, wer entscheidet
denn jetzt nun, dass jetzt alle Kimchi
Workshops überhaupt machen, das entscheidet
wieder der eurozentrische
Gaumen entscheidet jetzt, das ist
jetzt lecker, das ist jetzt cool, das ist jetzt
hip, für Essen, für das wir- also ich mit vielleicht
traditionell afrikanischem,
ostafrikanischem Essen, vielleicht du
mit koreanischem Essen, vietnamesischem Essen,
wofür man früher in der Schule gemobbt
wurde, wurde jetzt entschieden, jetzt ist
-es lecker, aber weil wir es lecker machen.
-Ihr habt nicht viel Ahnung vom Essen. Wir
sind jetzt an einen Punkt gekommen,
wo ihr echt nicht wisst, wovon ihr redet.
Also ich meine, wenn es einen
Verlierer gibt in Deutschland, dann ist
es der Anbieter von Eisbein
und Sauerkraut. Die Jungs, die darauf
spezialisiert waren, sozusagen
auf deutsches Essen, die haben über
die letzten 30, 40 Jahre
wirklich verloren. Wer so eine Klitsche noch
aufmacht, der kann sich also
seine drei Kunden an einer Hand abzählen.
Das es jetzt immer eine Frage
sozusagen sei gerade der Mode. Also ich weiß nicht,
japanische Restaurants in Düsseldorf
zum Beispiel, wo es eine starke japanische
Community gibt, die gibt es seit
30, 40 Jahren. Da pilgern die Leute hin,
haben zum Teil ein halbes Jahr
vorher einen Tisch reserviert und wissen ganz
-genau, warum sie da hingehen.
-Aber das war ja nicht immer so. Das
-mussten sie sich ja hart erkämpfen.
-Das ist seit 30, 40 Jahren so, das ist die
Entwicklung unseres Landes. Und ich kann
nur sagen, wenn die beiden, also
wenn sozusagen die thailändische Küche
jetzt im Schnellrestaurant von zwei weißen
Guys gemacht wird, tough luck, warum sind
denn die anderen nicht auf die Idee
kommen? Das ist nun wirklich eine Welt,
die allen offensteht. Warum? Warum sind
das zwei- Ja, es waren zwei Weiße,
die offenbar- die die Idee hatten. Dann fass
ich mir doch selber an die Nase und sage,
pass mal auf, warum bin ich selbst nicht
-auf die Idee gekommen?
-Und das ist ja nicht eurozentrisch, dass
wir sagen, wir eurozentrischen Leute
entscheiden, was jetzt geschmackvoll ist
oder was nicht, sondern wir alle
miteinander. Du, ich, wir alle sagen:
Wo gehen wir hin und wo gehen wir nicht
hin? Das kann jeder selbst entscheiden.
Das ist alles Entwicklung im Zuge
von kultureller Aneignung. Da kann ich mir
-nur wünschen: Mehr davon.
-Ich find's wahnsinnig interessant, in
welche Auswüchse die Diskussion hier
überhaupt gehen kann. Es war mir vorher
nicht so ganz klar, dass wir über
solche Details auch sprechen würden, aber so sind
wir hier nun mal. Und ihr steht
genauso wie am Anfang alle drei jeweils ganz
hinten. Das ist deswegen interessant,
weil wir jetzt in eine Kompromissrunde
einsteigen wollen. Und jetzt wäre es eure Aufgabe,
also einen Kompromissvorschlag
zu definieren, um die jeweils andere
Seite nach vorne zu locken. Ich mache mal einen
Vorschlag. Es ist bei diesem Thema,
wie so oft; klingt jetzt vielleicht banal
oder oberflächlich, aber ich suche
jetzt erst mal den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner.
Also, wenn ich das jetzt mal alles
zusammenfasse, dann habe ich den Eindruck,
dass die Diskussion um das Thema
kulturelle Aneignung schon
deswegen wichtig ist, weil sie Diskriminierung
ans Tageslicht bringt,
von denen vielleicht eine, ich sage
mal, pauschal weiße Mehrheitsgesellschaft gar
nicht so viel Ahnung hat. Das ist
schon mal eher ein Vorteil, dass man überhaupt
darüber diskutiert. Können wir uns
jetzt also darauf einigen, dass erst
die Auseinandersetzung mit dem kulturhistorischen
Hintergrund beim
Hip-Hop, bei Frisuren, bei Augen,
also Wissensvermittlung, überhaupt uns
in die Lage versetzt, Wertschätzung
dafür auszustrahlen? Wenn ihr sagt, ja,
das stimmt, das ist mal das erste, was wir machen
müssen, dann könnt einen Schritt
nach vorne gehen. Wenn ihr sagt,
Kackformulierung, bleibt ihr einfach
stehen. Okay, immerhin. Also
anderthalb, anderthalb Leute haben so einen halben
Schritt gemacht. Du
bist sogar zurückgegangen.
Ich will doch nicht jedes
Mal, wenn ich jetzt in ein Café gehe
und was mit fremdländischen
Namen bestelle-
-Stimme ich dir zu.
--vorher einen Test machen müssen, ob ich
auch den kulturellen Hintergrund
begriffen habe von dem Produkt, das ich kaufen will.
Naja, so war es auch nicht gemeint. Es war
ja so gemeint- es war ein Plädoyer dafür,
sich mehr als bis es heute
passiert mit kulturellen Backgrounds
auseinanderzusetzen. Ist
also eine Bildungsfrage eigentlich.
Also wenn du mir sagst, dass es gut
ist, mich für andere Kulturen zu interessieren,
-da bin ich immer dabei.
-Mehr als jetzt, weil das uns erst in die
Lage versetzt zu sagen: Ok, ich verstehe
jetzt erst mal deinen Punkt. Oh, du hast-
mit deinen Haaren verbindest du
etwas anderes, als ich es hier gedacht habe?
-Darum geht es.
-Also für Aufklärung bin ich immer.
Ja, das ja, aber das darf zum Beispiel
nie dazu führen, dass man sich unbedingt
mit indischer Kultur befassen
muss, bevor man ins Yoga Studio geht.
Jetzt dürft ihr euch die Köpfe
zusammenstecken in eurer Gruppe.
Merkt euch bitte eure Position
ungefähr und versucht mal eine Formulierung,
einen Satz, einen Appell
loszuwerden, um die anderen zu euch zu ziehen.
...wir pochen ja
immer auf dieses "verboten"...
...Leute profitieren
ja, werden ja Millionäre...
Also, was würdet ihr formulieren,
um diese beiden Gruppen enger aneinander
zu bringen? Wir haben ja schon
viele Differenzen jetzt gerade gesehen
und das ist vielleicht auch schon mal
eine Erkenntnis. Aber wie kriegen wir jetzt
die Menschen näher zusammen bei dieser Frage?
Ich bin sehr gespannt. Schreib
-es bitte in die Kommentare.
-...aber Kultur gehört ja keinem...
...dass du mit Schwarzen aufgewachsen
bist, zählt nicht, weil du hast eine weiße
Hautfarbe, auch dieses mit dem weiß
gelesen werden, alles Käse. Du bist weiß,
-fertig aus.
-Wer würde gerne anfangen? Wollt ihr
anfangen? Habt ihr einen
Kompromissvorschlag?
Wir würden uns gern
erst die Gegenseite anhören.
-Ist das okay für euch?
-Nein.
-Echt nicht?
-Wie nein? Dann müssen wir losen.
-Okay, dann losen wir.
Das ist zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte
von 13 Fragen, dass die beiden Parteien
sich nicht einigen konnten, wer beim
Kompromißvorschlag anfängt. Aber so machen
wir das. Ich such mal eine Münze oder so
was. Ich habe ein altes Plektrum, das hat
eine Spitze. Seht ihr das hier? Es gibt
eine Spitze. Wenn die Spitze- ich schmeiß
es- dahin, wo die Spitze näher hin
zeigt, derjenige fängt bitte an, oder die Gruppe
fängt an. In Ordnung? Ich werfe es einfach
hoch. Die Spitze zeigt klar zu euch.
-Das heißt, ihr sollt bitte anfangen.
-Alles klar. Also, unser Kompromiss würde
so lauten, dass wir, komplett von Geboten
oder Verboten komplett absehen wollen
würden und überhaupt nicht der Meinung
sind, Menschen vorschreiben zu wollen,
ob sie sich jetzt ihre Haare so
flechten oder was sie sich anziehen, welches Tattoo
sie machen, das ist natürlich
jedem Menschen liegt komplett frei,
oder ob sie ein erfolgreiches
Kimchi Restaurant eröffnen oder nicht.
Und unser Appell oder unser Wunsch
dabei ist, einfach noch mal zu bedenken: Wen
kann ich mit an den Tisch holen? Mit wem
könnte ich meine Privilegien teilen,
-der strukturell einfach benachteiligt ist?
-Es gab Bewegung. Angelina ist ein bisschen
-stehengeblieben.
-Das war ausversehen.
Das finde ich grundsätzlich gut.
Ich finde es nur problematisch dann doch,
wenn ich daran denke, dass die erste
Aussage von dir war, ich würde nicht
Kundin werden bei ihr.
Das finde ich dann schon-
Wir sind ja durch den Prozess
mittlerweile gegangen.
Dann ist im Grunde genommen dieser Vorschlag,
dieser Kompromissvorschlag
schon für mich eigentlich nicht so
wirklich- steht nicht auf zwei festen
-Beinen.
-Wollen wir auch anerkennen, wie sie sagt,
wir sind durch den Prozess
durchgegangen und jetzt sind wir hier am Ende
-dieses Prozesses.
-Ja, aber der Prozess bedeutet, sie muss
sich erst mal stundenlang
erklären, wer sie ist, was ihre Herkunft ist,
welchen Bezug sie hat zu Schwarzen,
zur schwarzen Community. Und erst dann wird
akzeptiert, dass sie das tut. Und das finde
ich inakzeptabel. Das muss
-sie nicht.
-Okay, wir sind aber jetzt in der
Kompromiss Runde. Der Vorschlag
wurde gemacht. Du bist nach vorne gegangen,
-jetzt seid ihr dran.
-Wichtig ist, dass wir diejenigen
kritisieren, die zu kritisieren sind,
also diejenigen, die sich lustig machen über
Augenform, Hautfarbe, Haare, was auch immer.
Die sollten wir kritisieren
und die sollten wir versuchen zu bilden,
von mir aus auch zu erziehen, aber nicht
allgemeine Forderungen zu stellen,
"Man sollte das nicht, oder ich finde
problematisch dass...", weil das ist
nicht problematisch, in meiner Sicht ist
es nicht problematisch. Das setzt
aber voraus, dass man eigene Verletztheit
zumindest überdenkt. Ich meine, man
ist verletzt, dass man dann aber auch wieder
sagt, okay, aber das ist vielleicht
mein persönliches Problem, ich bin vielleicht
verletzt aus einem ganz anderen Grund,
weil ich nämlich ständig beleidigt wurde.
Aber derjenige, der jetzt sich die Augen
auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise schminkt,
der verletzt mich in Wahrheit ja
gar nicht. Sondern das ist eigentlich
derjenige oder diejenige, die sich
lustig gemacht hat. Das heißt, dass man
auch seine eigene Position kritisch
vielleicht hinterfragt mal, um insgesamt
-wieder ein Miteinander mehr zu schaffen.
-Alex, du kriegst das Schlusswort.
Hier war ja gerade die Rede
von "die richtigen Leute erziehen",
die die Aggressoren sind, die die tatsächlich
irgendwie Stereotype in Form
von Mobbing nach außen tragen oder so,
aber das leugnet ja so ein Stück weit,
dass es eben strukturellen
Rassismus gibt in dieser Gesellschaft,
dass es auch positiven Rassismus gibt
in dieser Gesellschaft. Und das sind ja alles
Probleme, die irgendwie
zusammenführen zu der Diskussion, die wir heute geführt
haben über kulturelle Aneignung.
Deswegen muss ich sagen, habe ich dazu gedacht,
dass es, so, auch wenn ich jetzt
nicht rassistisch gemobbt habe, sind mir
in meiner Erziehung, in Kindheitstagen,
auf dem Spielplatz, im Kindergarten
und wo auch immer irgendwie
rassistische Stereotype ja auch verinnerlicht worden.
Und ich habe die auch verinnerlicht
und muss ja auch daran arbeiten,
auch wenn ich jetzt kein
Aggressor bin oder mich nicht als solcher-
Aber du fühlst dich als Teil
eines strukturell rassistischen Systems.
Genau, und möchte an diesem System
arbeiten und an mir arbeiten. Ja.
Ich habe schon glaube ich verstanden
was du meinst, aber ich finde es auch okay,
zum Schluss dann zu sagen, dann trennt
und wirklich was. Können ja viele Leute gar
-nicht aushalten.
-Ich kann das an sich auch definitiv gut
-aushalten.
-Du wirktest auch so
Und ich glaube, das ist auch wichtig,
Pluralität gut aushalten zu können.
Gleichzeitig frage ich mich
einfach, inwieweit es für dich sozusagen
-darum ging, tatsächlich dagegen zu sein.
-Ich bin gegen das, wenn du so willst,
Gesellschaftsmodell, was ich natürlich
dahinter wittere. Wenn du sagst
zu Angelina, letztlich kann ich in deinen
Salon gar nicht gehen, weil du bist
-weiß...
-Was ich nie gesagt habe, dass ich das
-nicht kann.
-Oder du nicht willst, oder so. Und gar
nicht, weil du sagst, ich- und das würde
ich sofort verstehen- ich trau dir nicht
zu, dass du mit schwarzen Haaren
umgehen kannst, da würde ich sofort sagen,
um Gottes Willen, ich lass doch
nicht jeden an meine Haare, sondern du es ja
zu einer Frage der Identität machst.
Und da glaube ich, trennt uns, da trennt uns
-ganz viel.
-Ich hoffe trotzdem, dass einige Sachen und
Details klar geworden sind. Nicht
nur allen hier, vor allem die Positionen
der anderen, sondern hoffentlich auch euch
an eurem mobilen Endgerät. Das war 13
Fragen, herzlichen Dank dafür! Nach meinem
Eindruck geht es bei der ganzen Debatte
gar nicht so sehr um eine harte
Trennlinie, um Gesetze: Was darf man noch,
was darf man nicht? Sondern, wie bei so
vielen Debatten, geht es ganz banal
um Wertschätzung, Wertschätzung von kulturellen
Identitäten. Und natürlich
dürfen und sollen sich Kulturen
miteinander vermischen, sich gegenseitig
befruchten. Aber über allem steht
die Maßgabe: Sei einfach kein Arschloch.
Ich finde es gar nicht so schwer.
Wenn euch 13 Fragen gefällt, dann könnt
ihr hier unseren Kanal abonnieren.
Hier oben findet ihr eine weitere Folge 13
Frage und hier gibt es ein weiteres Video
zum Thema.